terrasser des yeux joli robe pour mon
attire pas j'en dis pas demain où on a
payé tes voyous des voyous ou tes whyo
tes boules à
saisirons mon attire pas gentil pas
demain ou on a payé merci kiki mari à
part retrouver un hôtel là pour cause du
nouvel album du groupe sabuk vision
gramoun pour que sa vision granool mais
parce que le temps a passé et il va
finir avec l'âge les grands moules
pratiquement et puis nous on a une
vision des choses maintenant c'est voilà
quoi ça donne ce titre là une vision sur
quoi de quoi je finis par l'anneau
de ce qui se passe dans notre petit pays
tout tout les les bons et les mauvais
côtés donc j'essaye de de parler un
petit peu ça ma manière avec mes textes
et la musique
[Musique]
et poser finalement le regard
expérimenté du groupe sabuk sur ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui avec le temps avec
le
recul qu'il y a ben on arrive à voir les
choses un peu plus posées et puis
l'analyse ne se fait plus de la même
manière et donc du coup ça nous permet
de voir de d'aller à l'essentiel et de
dire les choses telles qu'on les ressent
toujours dans ce registre jazz maloya là
c'est vraiment une espèce de fusion
entre le maloya et de l'improvisation en
fait de toute façon quand on écoute les
premiers notes de l'album on entend tout
de suite du sabot que les gens qui ont
la primeur d'écouter l'album on dit ça
sonne ça bout quoi
[Musique]
une nation plus loin que ça
de vivre au jour le jour je crois que
c'est plus important que de se lancer
dans des projets moi je vous consacre
plus à la musique parce que j'aime faire
dans l'instant présent et après si ça
vient ça veut dire que c'est du mérite
quelque part et continue donne un coup
de fouette à la musique